[Musique]
bienvenue ravi de vous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle saison de Paris Saclay TV
à la une cette question qui se pose
chaque jour davantage avec le
réchauffement climatique comment
anticiper notre façon de nous déplacer
l'eau in l'opération d'intérêt national
menée par le PA Paris Saclay ytravail
nous verrons comment et parmi les
initiatives lancées il y a Clem c'est
l'opérateur choisi par le PA Paris
Saclay pour mettre en place cette
mobilité électrique sur l'ensemble du
territoire nous avons rencontré son
président Bruno flinoir le développement
durable il passe aussi par la
revalorisation des terres excavées lors
des travaux d'aménagement vous verrez
comment on peut transformer ce limon
inerte en terre végétal pour le
réutiliser à suivre
de Julien mon voisin et les chefs de
projet à l'EPA Paris Saclay notre agenda
enfin il est très vert vous verrez et ce
sera à la fin de cette émission
[Musique]
comment mettre en place une mobilité
décarbonée une mobilité durable le PA
Paris sacré et ses partenaires se
mobilisent pour anticiper les usages de
demain véhicules électriques
stationnement intelligent covoiturage
voici quelques pistes de réflexion et
d'action des enjeux qui étaient au coeur
d'une conférence sur la mobilité durable
elle s'est tenue ici même à centrale
Supélec nous y étions
à l'occasion de la Semaine européenne de
la mobilité le PA Paris Saclay a
organisé deux tables rondes réunissant
des experts de la mobilité durable des
acteurs de la R&D ainsi que des
opérateurs de mobilité pour débattre des
usages de la mobilité d'aujourd'hui et
des innovations de demain
tous les acteurs présents à ces tables
rondes on convergé pour expliquer que la
ville durable doit absolument limiter
l'usage du véhicule individuel au profit
des nouvelles mobilités que sont le
covoiturage l'autopartage ou les modes
actifs
tant que toutes ces nouvelles mobilités
souhaitent être actives et permettent
demain à tout à chacun de les utiliser
il faut que elle s'insère correctement
dans les espaces urbains pour faciliter
les correspondances avec les transports
en commun et que des aménagements soient
suffisamment sécurisés pour justement
encourager le changement de comportement
et donc pour maîtriser la place de la
voiture ça veut dire que derrière il
faut arriver à coordonner les politiques
de stationnement d'aménagement et de
mobilité pour tendre vers un partage de
l'espace public c'est dans cette
perspective de quartier apaisé et des
carbonés que le PA Paris Saclay a
impulsé aux côtés des acteurs publics et
privés un certain nombre de solutions
innovantes pour accompagner le
changement de comportement on peut citer
le stationnement intelligent qui permet
de reporter le véhicule vers des places
en ouvrage
mutualisée ainsi qu'une solution la
mobilité électrique partagée qui permet
de rendre accessible à la fois aux
salariés et au grand public
un service de recharge accéléré ainsi
que à des offres d'autopartage que ça
pour la mobilité professionnelle ou des
déplacements du grand public
la semaine européenne de la mobilité et
l'occasion pour nous aménageurs et
collectivités de faire découvrir ces
nouvelles solutions de mobilité aux
usagers du campus et c'est l'objet des
animations qui ont été présentées
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
parmi les projets accompagnés par le PA
par Saclay il y a la mise en place d'une
mobilité électrique collaborative sur le
campus urbain et c'est la société Clem
qui a été choisie Clem qui propose un
service d'autopartage mais aussi un
service de recharge électrique des
véhicules le tout avec une seule et même
application nous avons rencontré son
président brunoflinois
[Musique]
Clem est une société spécialisée dans
l'autopartage et la recharge de
véhicules électriques en 2022 nous avons
remporté le contrat de concession du
plateau de Saclay un groupement de
commandes avec les universités l'ACPS
l'établissement public pour promouvoir
la mobilité électrique à l'échelle du
plateau alors comment ça marche pour les
utilisateurs il faut s'inscrire sur le
site clem.mobi une fois inscrit on va
pouvoir réserver un véhicule en
autopartage après avoir mis son permis
de conduire et avoir été validé pour la
recharge il suffit de s'inscrire aussi
sur Clem quoi Moby ou d'avoir un badge
déjà d'un autre opérateur et de venir
juste se recharger sur les bornes de
charges
le système de facturation est lié à la
consommation horaire et kilowatts
aujourd'hui Clem est le seul acteur du
marché a proposé à la fois de
l'autopartage électrique et à la fois
des services de bande de charge
l'intérêt est de promouvoir une mobilité
décarbonée et partagée à l'échelle d'un
territoire à travers une seule
application les usagers peuvent trouver
tous les services à leur disposition
voire s'inscrire réserver payer et voir
leur bilan carbone à l'échelle du
plateau sur les 5 années à venir notre
objectif est premièrement de proposer
des usages forfait Flex des forfaits
garantis sur des véhicules de notre
flotte en autopartage mais aussi de
proposer à l'ensemble des acteurs du
territoire de venir se recharger sur les
bornes du territoire et dans un deuxième
temps notre objectif est de rencontrer
chacun des acteurs les acteurs de
l'immobilier les collectivités et les
entreprises qui travaillent sur le
plateau pour voir avec elle en fonction
de leurs besoins et de leurs contraintes
comment les aider à rentrer dans une
mobilité partagée et une mobilité
électrique c'est à dire des carbonées
donc nous avons trois offres
premièrement une offre deux positionner
des bornes de charges pour leur compte
de positionner des voitures pour leur
flotte et de partager les bornes de
charges et les véhicules soit en interne
soit avec le tout public selon des
règles définies par eux le campus de
Paris Saclay est une référence au niveau
mondial avec des acteurs variés et des
besoins variés de mobilité
ce campus est voué à ce densifier
énormément dans les années à venir et
Clem est là pour accompagner ce
développement tout en proposant une
mobilité décarbonée et partagée
pour démarrer la voiture je mets le pied
sur frein j'appuie sur Start Stop
je mets ma ceinture
toujours le pied sur le frein je vais me
mettre en position drive je retire le
frein à main
et je vous dis à plus tard
[Musique]
vous les avez certainement remarqué aux
abords des chantiers sur les talus des
milliers de mètres cubes de terre sont
excavées lors des travaux d'aménagement
du territoire notamment au sud du
plateau ce limon inerte et de plus en
plus revalorisée alors comment le
transformer en terre végétal pour le
réutiliser tout de suite les
explications de Julia mon voisin il est
chef de projet à le PA Paris Saclay
[Musique]
l'établissement public d'aménagement
Paris-Saclay génère un volume important
de limon inerte issu des des opérations
de terrassement suite aux travaux
d'aménagement que l'on mène sur
l'ensemble des actes du Sud plateau
il était donc important de créer une
filière de revalorisation de ces terres
l'opération consiste à caractériser ces
terres donc en faisant des sondages pour
s'assurer que les terres ne sont pas
trop pollués chimiquement
ensuite on effectue un tri on enlève les
déchets tout ce qui peut être déchets
plastiques ou déchets externes apportés
par des tiers une fois que le tri
effectué on met en stock notaire et on y
ajoute du compost
issus des déchets verts et on termine
par la mise en place d'un couvert
végétal qui va créer des racines au sein
de ses stocks ce qui va permettre à la
biodiversité de se développer et d'aérer
les terres et de la Transformer non pas
en limon mais en terre végétale
sur cette opération donc avec les stocks
que l'on voit derrière moi on a
revalorisé 50 000 m3 et on a un taux de
revalorisation de 95%. donc ce qui est
une amélioration assez conséquente
depuis la première opération de
remédiation que l'on avait mené sur la
ZAC de Polytechnique et de corbeille
en termes d'utilisation ces stocks de
terre d'ici 2 à 3 ans on aura à dispo de
la terre végétale que l'on pourra
utiliser pour nos aménagements sur
l'ensemble des espaces publics des trois
actes et également pourquoi pas
en proposer à des agriculteurs qui
voudraient l'utiliser en terre
agronomique donc pour l'agriculture on
sait que cela va subvenir aux besoins
dans un premier temps pour l'aménagement
de la ZAC de Moulon de corbeille et de
Polytechnique mais avec un stock aussi
conséquent on arrivera aussi sûrement à
en laisser aux collectivités à qui on va
rétrocéder les espaces publics dans
quelques années
[Musique]
et maintenant notre agenda avec la aussi
de nombreux rendez-vous autour du
développement durable avec les 5 et 6
octobre des balades à la découverte de
la biodiversité du campus urbain et des
mesures prises en oeuvre pour la
préserver balade organisée par le PA
Paris Saclay dans le cadre des semaines
européennes du développement durable
autre initiative très originale les
échappées vertes c'est le dimanche 9
octobre vous pourrez découvrir les
espaces agricoles et naturels protégés
du plateau de Saclay avec un immense
escape game en plein air avec là aussi
des animations sur la nature et
l'agriculture locale à faire en famille
évidemment et n'oubliez pas vous avez
jusqu'au 9 octobre justement pour
profiter des randos durables balades
animations toutes les villes du
territoire sont mobilisées et enfin les
cobalades c'est le samedi 15 octobre une
marche organisée sur un parcours jalonné
de microconférence autour du
développement durable l'occasion là
aussi de découvrir et de visiter les
espaces naturels et agricoles du
territoire mais aussi de rencontrer des
acteurs locaux de l'environnement vous
l'aurez compris ce mois d'octobre et
celui du développement durable alors
profitez-en c'est la fin de ce numéro
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite et pour rester
informé une seule adresse un seul site
eparé sa clé.fr à très bientôt
[Musique]